[Music]
in father-daughter bonding news can't
really love your dad I do I love him now
we did not get along when I when we were
growing up it was not like daddy's
little girl type thing no it was like
he'd [ __ ] yell at me for everything
and I feel like your daddy's little
athlete yeah and like okay I'm happy he
did that because I'm very disciplined
yeah like man I was really sad as a kid
trauma was working yeah feel like that's
the the woes of Asian parenting is that
you appreciate them when you're 80 years
old and you're like oh that's why they
when you're 80 yeah when you're 80 and
that's when you go oh yeah they I got it
now that's why I started really 25 later
a single dad went viral after asking his
daughter for fashion advice oh I heard
about this that's nice he's like trying
to get [ __ ] so I got how to dress he's
trying to leave his wife
what do you think about this shirt up
why do you want to know it's like well
try to divorce your mom so she's a real
drag all right so this tweet went viral
on Twitter and all right so well first
of all this is Carly and her dad Jeff
so he's single he's ready to mingle and
he was getting ready for a date when he
when he texted her these outfit photos
and then she ended up tweeting it life
with a single dad asking for advice on
date outfit slang face my heart yeah and
then so she's like giving him advice I
can't suck it with it with the belts and
then another with the other shirt
they're doing Joey you know what I'm
thinking about no pressure
this is I'm sorry for this is just the
way that I think he's an older dude
probably doesn't know how to use his
phone is getting ready for a date Joe
probably took a dick pic let's be honest
here and he's trying to send to the date
to the person maybe he's flirting right
and people you'd be surprised what the
hell do you take something adorable no
I'm not done I'm not done Nicky now he's
trying to say to why he's trying he's
also trying to like take photos of
himself to see what a submit and he
sends the wrong one to like parents and
children
yes we're like the mom the mom was uh
she took like a an ass picture it's a
personal story by the way laughter
anyway what we did a story here um yeah
so the mom was just taking provocative
pictures for whatever dude she's dating
at the time I said accidental he sent it
to her son who's just like oh I could
see is just the his photos how he
clearly doesn't know how to take photos
to like just by the way he's posing I I
feel that the probability of that
happening is too damn high I recently
saw one it was a grandma and in the text
was oh grandma what's up it was like oh
I'm sorry my poor child you had to see
that oh man what did the grandma show
her titties were like down to her
[ __ ] ankles No
damn I know this is nice there comes a
time when nudity becomes offensive no
sex involved in this one but it does I
mean it doesn't have like a super happy
ending because he did get stood up that
night also she was just like you know
what he got home that night he was
really sad I didn't want to make him sad
and mad on the same night so I told him
the next morning when she tweeted out
the photos he went viral he did go viral
huh she probably has a lot of dates now
because we don't know the follow-up is
probably all these other ladies like
I'll [ __ ] date him I actually looked
at the the replies in that tweet and
there's so many people would be like hey
tell your dad to hit me up and like
those bad photos or like be like my
mom's single and that's such a good
relationship you're like oh what a
family-oriented guy yeah
stable trusting single I know and
where's the ex-wife he might be a great
father to the daughter but a horrible
[ __ ] spouse has been true that's true
we could share on it yeah any good story
we know this from experience what we
know but we could say this because we
are shitty spouses but great parents
that's why you have a kid animals oh
yeah I'm wonderful dog owner horrible
boyfriend horrible I didn't know all of
you guys I know I know
yeah we all know your secret yes yes yes
we all agree with you no no you're all
in it you're all in it you're all in it
you guys are you can't be alone in this
can feelin we're pretty happy come on
camera they're lying to you don't let
her lie look they seem friendly
yeah scene wow that is so cute
that's why I'm worried about being a bad
mom cuz I'm like no no my relationships
too good I can't have a boat oh yeah
shitty parent yeah andin but like being
good with your husband when they're 80
yeah cuz I like how you and Steve fight
with your imaginary kid okay I think
that's great parenting like you're
practicing on the same team like how
we'd be talking [ __ ] like we're gonna
talk [ __ ] this way your dad okay yeah
one of my favorite things is to wait for
Tiger I like disrespect her and I could
step in at that man oh he doesn't do
that though he doesn't cost like that
but he's like hey don't know it your mom
like that I'm like okay
shut the [ __ ] up little [ __ ] give us
some boxing gloves yeah thank us facial
expressions are exactly like bars oh
yeah I like even just now when you did
that smile but then he has like Gio's
features yeah
yeah my mom says that Tiger gives her
the same condescending look that you
give my mom she swears that you give her
this look and I'm like nah his face is
just like what's my my 12 your mom one
time I told your mom one thing oh and
then she was like that's the statement
that everyone's been telling me and I'm
like what I don't know apply something
about like laundry or dishes or
something unless you mean by that
she was just like I don't know what
let's take my time she goes everyone
tells me
bart's really goofy but the minute he
tells you one command it sticks in your
brain and you're serious I'm like really
I met that pretty light heart of it too
it's cuz you're a Scorpio we don't mean
to be intense people just take it down
yeah I was just like I was probably like
oh can you can you wash my thong
something like that it's a hard because
you know all the thongs that we do own
it's the animal ones we have a silver
what in a gold was like both of you
together together in the songs JK needed
money early on I understand how it works
you got a dance every now and then it
didn't work so we're here now okay no
they made a lot of money I could tell
but I pictured the gold and [ __ ]
silver elephant thugs that we have and a
lot of it what condescending fiend is
your mom say no you say to her yeah a
fail you know what what's this so one of
the ones that were you got my brother so
my brother wanted to know something
about the gym right instead of my
instead of Bart finding out what this
thing about the gym was he just told him
I don't know that's not my thing that's
Geo's thing and then kind of left the
text conversation at that my brother was
like who's that how's that hot ascending
uh no it's just really rude it's just
rude I really don't know the answer my
Chinese the polite thing would be like
oh let me find out cuz it's a one-off
type question so it's just manners you
know you don't get them off and go I
don't know that's not my thing go get a
tip like that's [ __ ] up I'm like what
good time no it's cuz you're sure you
sister I'm sure and you know more I know
but it's probably a way to bond to he
that's why you get you up brother-in-law
right he is Chinese what about the face
thing though that that's a text thing so
yeah I don't know I don't know the
specifics cuz she's like I don't know
it's just this face that he gives me
where I feel really stupid because for
me I think it's no face that you get
that's probably what scares her yeah
we're very expressive like just as like
a culture we're very expressive that you
can you know what's going on expressive
you have a great poker face
Cameron he can't even hold it what
should I do like this just express
everything lips scary I mean I've been
in business dealings with you when we're
in trying yes and you just uh know you
have a calm collected demeanor I'd say
it's harder yeah it's I would say it's
harder to read so maybe someone it could
come across as condescending to someone
else if if you just say something very
hard I think that from a business
standpoint I think it's good we actually
we've sent bharden on a few occasions on
text chat or whatnot just to deliver the
bad news you won't say like Bart so
here's what's gonna go down man like you
like got it I'll just say it like
whatever or in person you've done it so
works for us what know that you're just
the bearer of bad news and you have no
expression like that's giving people bad
news that barks like this like cuz most
people are scared to give that we know
we don't want to fire the guy so it's
like a boy would you do the dirty work
all right [ __ ] it
Jake you've been doing a really good job
thing is we gotta let you go
very cold that's it thanks for your time
he's like I say good job you've been
crushing it we don't need you gonna love
with the rest of you endeavours like so
I was listening to this speech about
agreeableness and non agreeableness
right so people that tend to be more
bosses that tend to be more agreeable
they they don't like firing people right
but what's the opposite of agreeable I
forgot what it was but whatever it is
disagreeable they're in there into
confrontation and [ __ ] right so it's
just that we see things so differently
right cuz like I don't like to I don't
like to feel like I fail on people so I
think I lean more the agreeable side
yeah and and so I don't like to fire
them because I feel like people can
change and they can work on it or
whatever
yeah the people that don't think that
way they can't wait to fire people
because they're like you're
I'm agreeable I see that's like I'm
wasting I see cousin voicing their time
no we're not they're not you're not
disagreeable you're pre agreeable
because you have retain workers like JK
retain workers like if it's got to be
really [ __ ] bad in order for you to
let them go yeah I think that's your
department but for the gym I wasn't like
that oh oh you are like from outside
looking in you are agree more if you
don't like the word but you are
agreeable sounds like people-pleaser
yeah it's not it's not yeah yeah it
doesn't mean so you got to understand so
anyways no but you have a misperception
of yourself yeah yeah you know you're
not a bad [ __ ] okay he's like yeah yeah
selphie stop trying to be so she's being
sarcastic job like Jude you're not bad
at stuff okay okay I got it
anyways going back to what I was saying
is if you are not agreeable right like
if you're that kind of boss the way you
see it is you go these people are
wasting my resources these people are
causing disruption these people are
[ __ ] milking my system they need to
get the [ __ ] out Oh two completely
different type of perspective one is
like oh you know what they're just going
through a hard time right now let me
talk to them and see if they need help
or maybe they're just not acting like
themselves so it's like when you get
these two together though if they make a
really good team right because when two
is when they're too agreeable they
retain people to the end towards and
yeah yeah and then the other side is
like they're constantly firing people
because they don't know how to work
through any problem right yeah that
makes sense
[Applause]
[Music]